and we're going to have another session
of understanding anger 2.0 and while
people are streaming in I'll tell you a
little bit wh what's going on looks like
we're kind of stuck here
um okay it just updated looks like the
internet is a little bit glitchy here on
our end hopefully everybody is seeing
this all right I'm seeing uh the the
time tick a little bit
weirdly uh jumping forward by five
seconds at a time uh but be that as it
may um the there may be some
interference in the interwebs let's see
how things are going to go so what is
understanding anger 2.0 this came out of
a class that I was teaching at Marquette
University that has to do with anger and
how we should understand the phenomenon
of anger what it means for us as human
beings whether anger is good or bad and
bringing to Bear a whole bunch of useful
resources from uh philosophy literature
psychology theology a bunch of different
disciplines this session is going to be
about two
important um plays to tragedies coming
from the you know Classical period we
looked at echus last time and three of
his plays this time around we are going
to be looking at uh Sophocles the next
great Athenian playright and then we'll
look at ureides and so we've got these
two really Central plays for
understanding how anger works and and
the dangers involved in at the Ajax
which is about one of the great Heroes
of the Trojan War who ends his life
after the war and then um Meda which is
actually happening before that but is
written as a play later on and so
understanding anger um this this whole
series we did a earlier ver this for the
Kingston Public Library back in
was it
2015 and we decided to restart this and
there have been a couple interruptions
to it but we've gotten underway again so
uh we'll be walking our way this year
through a lot of Greek and Roman
thinkers talking about anger some of
them
philosophical some of them poetic uh
which Greek tragedy certainly is some of
them perhaps even
theological and then we're going to go
into a whole bunch of other uh venues
and traditions and works so let let's
talk first about these um plays as I
mentioned we looked last time at asus's
orista Trilogy which has to do with the
house of adrias they are going to play a
role in these uh plays that or play that
we're looking at here the Ajax because
Agamemnon who kind of a jerk and then
who's a different kind of jerk are both
antagonistic and
antagonizing uh not just Ajax but also
his brother so we're g to be looking at
at how those two fit in and I do want to
point out that both with the Ajax and
the Meda because they're plays they're
not philosophical
treatises or even you know rhetorical
speeches or anything like that they're
not giving us a theoretical Exposition
or or you know discussion or analysis of
how anger Works they're taking it for
granted that we understand this emotion
to some degree and they are depicting it
and having the characters talk about
who's angry and over what and what
they're going to do because of the anger
and we're also not getting a lot of um
you know lists of
practices or things that we can do to
lessen or control our anger but we're
going to see a model of it at least in
one of these plays with what it is that
adicus himself does but I think that
we're getting some really great
depictions of
anger and we could say that each of
these plays is also providing us with
something like a lesson
about how
to
um how to avoid falling into these kinds
of tragic and they really are tragic
situations and then what can we do
within them so um you know the the times
and places of these peoples are uh the
the actual writing of it is happening in
ancient Athens but the times are much
earlier in what we could call the heroic
or Bronze Age and you notice that
there's not a lot of
idealizing going on in these These are
times of brutal Warfare between other
people uh entire cities entire nations
fighting against each other the gods
themselves get involved and you know
really mess things up for people uh from
time to time as well and um we're going
to look at at at how this plays out in
just a moment I do want to highlight a
couple key themes now these are key
themes not just for this session but for
other sessions as well where we're
looking at let's call it literary
depictions of anger so we want to think
about why people get angry what causes
the anger response and you know we can
also think about whether it's a right
response a just response an appropriate
response or whether you know these
people getting angry in the way that
they do and behaving in the way that
they do um whether it's going too far or
too too easily uh aroused uh we also
want to think about the depictions of
how anger Works in a person experiencing
it I would say that this is particularly
important with Med who uh is going to
talk about being moved by her thumos a
term that we've encountered a lot before
and knowing that it is going to steer
her the wrong way but not being able to
Bridal it um you know we also encounter
we could we could say a morality of
anger or multiple moralities of anger as
we said maybe anger sometimes isn't the
appropriate response to the insults to
the Bel in to the sliding that's taking
place and you know this highlights the
relationship between anger and emotion
Justice and Injustice reasoning these
people explain what it is that they're
angry about they don't just have
something happen to them and then start
punching people they are actually
setting out what they're angry about and
what they're going to do uh about it and
then
finally this is quite important we see
that that
anger um doesn't exist in a
vacuum we often get angry because of
what other angry people do and so this
is going to be another really key theme
anger tends to spread itself within
multiple subjects who are related to
each other and very often the
retaliation or Vengeance or retribution
that the angry person is seeking if
they're successful in seeking it or even
unsuccessful as we're going to see with
Ajax in seeking it may arouse the anger
on the part of other people so um let's
jump into the Ajax because you know we
could say
Meda narratively comes first but
Sophocles is writing before ureides is
so this play is taking place as most
Greek tragedies do within a very very
narrow time frame and it's the aftermath
of a Slaughter that the Great Hero Ajax
who's one of the most important Heroes
on the Greek side in the Trojan War you
know we have Achilles we have adicus we
have diomedes we have a few other people
and then we have Ajax and Ajax is
depicted as this massive giant of a man
who with his mighty shield and spear is
able to slaughter Trojans he actually
stands up against Hector in single
combat and he's left as one of the
survivors at the end of the Trojan War
after Troy has been
sacked and what he ends up doing is
getting very very angry and deciding
upon Revenge now why does he do this
well Achilles who was you know
supposedly the greatest of the Greek
Heroes and you know we could think of
him as not necessarily like a superhero
above Ajax but they they're kind of
similar in in level um Achilles has died
Achilles um has been you know shot in
the Achilles tendon and um you know
knowing that that going and facing
Hector would lead to his own death um
he's go he's gone and chosen this path
of glory and now the question is all
right who is going to get Achilles armor
and weapons and this is a big deal
because these are trophies these are
things that are valuable that tell
people who you are and what you're worth
right so
Achilles um has left behind this we
could say bone of contention and and
achilles was you know he didn't really
like Agamemnon but he's friendly with
the rest of the Greek Heroes and
Agamemnon is the war leader menaus is
his brother and the two of them the
atres the sons of Atrius right of that
house are going to award the armor but
not to Ajax they're going to W it to
somebody who is kind of a rival of Ajax
adicus and you know why would they give
it to uus adicus is the guy who comes up
with the stratagy that leads to the
successful resolution at least for the
Greeks very unsuccessful for the Trojans
of the
war and so um Ajax views this as a
dishonoring as an insult to him and he
resolves to um
go and take
Vengeance and we get this
explanation uh from Athena she's saying
what happened um so Ajax decides that in
the middle of the night motivated by
anger in Greek holos right a term that
we've encountered many times before in
these sessions when looking at Homer and
hessi and and some of the other authors
Ajax uh is weighed down by his anger and
he decides that what he's going to do is
in the middle of the night sneak into
the Greek camp where he's already a a a
member right they're they're spread out
in their tents all over the place he is
with his uh fellows from his hometown of
simus and he's going to take captives
not of the Trojans but of the Greeks and
the captives that he's going to take are
going going to be the ones who have
injured his honor the ones who have
slighted him Agamemnon menus and in
particular
adicus what Athena does is places Ajax
into a a temporary state of insanity
where he feels his anger but his his
reason his sensibility has been taken
from him and so instead of getting these
um human beings he actually takes the
animals that are part of The Spoils of
War you know uh cattle and sheep and
stuff like that and he leads them it
also mentions dogs leads them into his
tent and he engages in a horrible and
dishonorable Slaughter of all of these
animals so this is you know an attempt
attt uh that goes astray an attempt to
impose retribution or Vengeance on the
Greeks and um we you know we wind up
getting a bunch of characters either
witnessing this or being told about this
and um then Athena is going to give Ajax
back his mind and when this happens
we're going to see that there's a let's
call it a shaming an embarrassment a
pain that will take place on
ajax's part and it's very interesting
the character adicus who is um you know
favored by Athena loved by Athena really
is not willing to participate in the um
what would you call it the the joy that
Athena is taking in the downfall of Ajax
and we're going to find out there's a
little bit bit of bad blood between the
two of them so Athena is inviting adus
to go and she's like check this guy out
let's go in the tent and and dsus is
like I don't want anything to do with
that um he uh he says I know that this
guy hates me but I also feel pity for
him and um adicus is going to say I see
that all we who live are nothing more
than Phantoms or Fleet Shadow so he's
got a sort of practical wisdom about
things and Athena says the day can press
down on all human beings and a day can
raise them up but the gods Embrace men
of sense and abore the evil so there's
some interesting wisdom being conveyed
here and then we get a a scene shift
Ajax and his uh people are going to be
the subject of that so we have the
chorus and the chorus here is ajax's uh
fellow soldiers from his hometown and
they want to know what God has led him
astray and they they mention that the
Greeks are now slandering him and his uh
concubine Tech Messa whose uh family
Ajax has actually killed and he's taken
her as a prize and uh impregnated her uh
she's already had a son she tells them
what has taken place during the night
and that a now sees his actions and she
mentions her fears about what is going
to happen to her um if Ajax takes you
know violent vengeance upon himself for
what he has done uh so Tech Messa is
saying this is a little bit of the play
she says to the
chorus which if the choice were given
you would you choose to distress your
friends and have joy your yourself or to
share the grief of friends who grieve
because Ajax now is grieving he is hurt
he is wounded by his own actions his
anger has gone astray because of what
Athena did to him and now is led to his
own uh lowering of social status the
chorus says the two-fold sorrow is
certainly the greater evil and Tech Mesa
says then we are ruined now though the
plague is passed and the chus says what
are you talking about and she says that
man that is uh Ajax while Afflicted
found joy for himself in the dire
fantasies that held him though his
presence distressed us who were sane but
now since he has had pause and resque
from the sickness he has been utterly
subjected to lowly anguish and we
similarly grieve no less than before
surely then these are two Sorrows
instead of one there is the sorrow of
Ajax and there is the sorrow of
everybody around him Ajax himself says
that he has been violated uh Hub is the
the Greek term there and you know we get
the word hubis uh at the core of that
hubus we usually think of as sort of
arrogance but it also means doing
something to another person because of
your arrogance and um he he you know he
still wishes evil to edsus but he
recognizes that it is a god Athena who
is bringing him to his doom and he says
what shall I do when I'm hated by the
gods abored by the Greek forces and
detested by all Troy and all these
Plains he's trying to figure out how can
I respond to my anger breaking out and
going
astray and so he says some Enterprise
must be sought whereby I may prove to my
aged father that that his son is not
gutless the options for a noble man are
only two either live with honor which is
no longer an option for him or make a
quick and honorable death so Ajax orders
that his son be taken to his parents and
given his shield and he's resolved to
end things and says I no longer owe
anything to these gods they have
essentially betrayed me but he also says
something quite
interesting he gives a final speech to
his followers where he talks about human
beings he says us who mean learning
self-restraint uh so throning to
exercise self-restraint or Temperance
and He suggests momentarily that he will
bow before the gods and the atres um
those who have awarded the O the honor
and the arms to
edsus he goes off stage and then his
brother shows up up tells her and he
says you know the Greeks not only are
looking for Ajax and they want to kill
him but they also first Jered at me then
they threw stones and then they swords
were drawn they were going to kill me
until the older men calmed down the
Greek crowd so you notice What's
Happening Here the Greeks are angry in
response to ajax's own response of anger
aren't they they want to do him in and
do him
harm and um we're told that a Ajax has
gone to get rid of his anger at the gods
below again we see the term holos being
used there for anger and then the
messenger tells them that Ajax should
have stayed in the tent and tells us a
little story about anger as well so up
until this point we've got anger Ajax
right anger of the Greeks but now we get
an anger before this that explains
Athena's actions Athena herself felt
anger or in this case at Ajax why
because she offered him help in fighting
against the Trojans telling him to raise
a murderous hand and he basically says
you go help out the other Greeks I got
this handled I can take care of it
myself so um that might have been the
right thing to do in a certain way but
it ticks off Athena and that's why she
did what she did to interfere with his
own anger so now we've got anger in a
number of different ways then we get
this scene where Ajax himself is going
to die and here if you remember last
time we talked about the the furies
these Greek spirits of the underworld
that come to um
uh impose retribution on those who take
the lives of their own kin in this case
we actually see Ajax invoking the furies
he says uh my miserable life is
destroyed by the uh Atri the sons of
Atrius come Swift and punishing Furies
Devour the assembled Army and spare
nothing so he's cursing all of the
Greeks mean while Tech Messa it mentions
that ajax's father is an angry man and
interestingly there's two different
anger terms that are getting used here
uh she says that he is an an oros
meaning that he's a man whose anger is
bad right du means bad and orgos is
coming from or and then she says um he
is his rage seeks quarrels without cause
proos thumos thumos is getting angry as
well and that uh over nothing in
relation to nothing
Pruden uh is how he will get angry and
then um menaus shows up on the scene
taer is there as well his brother and
now we're going to get a clash between
the Greeks represented by menus and toer
who is the half brother of Ajax and
menus and something that kind of Echoes
what happens with another play of
Sophocles that you might
remember uh is going to order that as a
betrayer ajax's corpse should not be
buried but should be left to be devoured
by the birds and he tells uh this to
tuser and says do not inflame my rage
and again they use menos to to describe
that and toer says this is the wrong
thing to do the you know the gods
require that he have a proper burial
Ajax was not your subject manalus he was
a free man fulfilling an oath you're the
guy who actually got us all in trouble
with your you know uh Helen who who
couldn't stay home and now they're
arguing with each other and they're not
just arguing about that they're also
arguing about who is actually a great
warrior or not and then menaus tells him
and again we see anger being talked
about what a tongue you have what
Dreadful anger thumos again here it
actually feeds and menaus will leave
toer orders the burial to begin
Agamemnon shows up and if you know
anything about Agamemnon he is a rageful
guy and very arrogant he's also the war
leader of the Greeks and he talks a lot
of trash and insults toer saying he a
slave and a son of a barbarian mother
and you know tser reminds Agamemnon that
Ajax was a hero on their side and that
tuser was at his side and there's
insults going back and forth and what is
going to lead to the resolution of
this adicus shows up and adicus in a
certain sense was part of the because of
the quarrel to begin with but adicus is
going to do something and here's where
we can get into some discussion so think
about what questions you want to ask or
what comments you want to make and I'll
address them after I tell you about uh
what adicus does which shows you
something about at least Sophocles
understanding of this guy adius arrives
and he ends up giving Council and he
actually tells uh
Agamemnon oh I don't think you're in the
right on this one
um you know you're getting insulted
because you're insulting and so it's
kind of hypocritical for you to be uh
concerned about somebody else insulting
you when you're being a jerk yourself
and then he says in the name of the gods
do not let yourself so ruthlessly cast
this man out unburied do not in any way
let the violence of your hatred overcome
you so much that you trample
Justice underfoot and now he's going to
give his own example and this is a very
powerful ethical
appeal to me too this man was once the
most hostile enemy in the Army from the
day on which I beat him for possession
of Achilles arms yet for all that he was
hostile towards me I would not dishonor
him in return or refuse to admit that in
all our Greek Force at Troy he was in my
view the best and bravest accepting
Achilles it would not be just then that
he should be Dishonored by you it is not
he but the laws given by the gods that
you would damage when a Good Man is dead
there is no justice in doing it him harm
e not even if you hate him so he's
talking about overcoming this rivalry
this relation of enemy to enemy and
recognizing the requirement
of justice and not just a Justice in
terms of Oaths or agreements but a
Justice that is in terms of
dessert of who merits what and
recognizing that and notice
this one of the things that anger tends
to do to us that we've noticed in uh
other discussions is it blinds us to
Justice while making use of a certain
limited conception of Justice Agamemnon
menus think they're they're doing the
right thing they're wrong about that
adicus is saying in wanting to expose
the
corpse Ajax was in a certain sense doing
the right thing um and uus is even
recognizing this by being upset that he
didn't get the arms of Achilles but
where he went wrong was deciding to take
Vengeance on all of the Greeks adicus
is overcoming this so in a certain way
he represents the rational part of a
human being uh recognizing our human
fallibility now notice the how it it's
actually going to close where we have an
overcoming of anger Agamemnon will leave
and so you guys do whatever the hell
you're G to do adicus says I am ready to
be T's friend as much as I was once his
enemy and I would like to join in the
burying of your dead and share your
labors admitting no service which
Mortals should render to their best and
Bravest Warriors and adicus and toer
become friends there's provisos uh
telser says you can't touch the body
because Ajax wouldn't want you to be
doing that but feel free to join in on
this with me so what we see here is a
very
interesting approach to anger and how
it's
overcome and so I think this is really
quite a valuable play that often isn't
attended to so before we go on to
Meda um any reactions questions comments
that you would like me to respond to
clarifications that you're looking at uh
insights that you'd like to express um
I'm happy to hear them to entertain them
to uh make sense of them as best as we
can uh again I don't think that there is
some to us but I think it's it's quite a
valuable piece for uh making sense of
this difficult
option
I'll take a little sip of coffee while
I'm waiting to see if anybody's got
anything they want to respond
about no it doesn't doesn't look like
I'm seeing any uh things in the chat
unless this
is no looks like it's it's working
right um although the interface is still
acting up a bit and showing me the time
in five minute or 5sec intervals which
is a little bit strange but all right
well let's talk about Meda then and I
think this is a much more famous play in
part because ancient
philosophers have often talked about how
important um this
particular play was for understand
understanding um not just anger but the
capacity of anger to overcome us it's
also an interesting one in that the main
character is a woman the Greeks were you
know definitely a p patriarchal society
tended to view women um as uh you know
less powerful uh less
intellectual uh less morally capable
than than men although the men weren't
often setting a great example in Greek
tragedy Med kind of stands out and she's
an
unusual
person um she is a princess in her own
right of a barbarian Kingdom of kulus
she sorceress she's very powerful as a
matter of fact you could say that um she
if we want to use contemporary parlance
she and Jason are not really a couple
because he is in some respects the
weakest and most pathetic of the Greek
Heroes um he needs Hercules to help him
out a lot of the way in the Argos and as
we're going to see he's kind of a
schmock in in many respects so we're
going to talk about the Rage of Meda and
it's mentioned again using these terms
like or anger holos rage thumos gets
brought up all all the time in this and
um one of the great lines is terrible
and hard to heal is the Wrath that comes
when kin join In conflict with kin and
it's or there wrath anger um this is a a
family struggle where they are fighting
against each other in certain ways so
the Meda opens up again as Greek
tragedies do right in the middle of
things
um Med is in a terrible and troubled
emotional state of holess of Rage
because something has happened she's
been married to Jason and she's had
children with him as
well Jason has decided that he wants to
set her aside which also means setting
the children aside and marrying a new
bride a younger bride GL the the
daughter of King cron of Corinth and you
know don't we see this often enough in
our own society when uh men will you
know abandon their their wives and
oftentimes their entire family to go off
and find somebody younger they use
language of you know like finding a
newer model sometimes they say trading
up but generally it isn't trading up
because the younger ones typically
aren't as wise and experienced as the
older ones right so um in her view she
has been wronged deeply wronged and she
talks about having a heavy deep brooding
mind or or heart and that she won't
accept this sort of insult or
dishonoring and we see that um it's not
just her heart that is heavy but also
her anger uh Bon organ a very
interesting way of combining two anger
words together Bon thumos is anger right
it's also the in some philosophers the
part we get angry with barus means deep
or heavy and then uran is uh Rage or
anger as well and in her own lines she's
so angry that at first she expresses the
wish that she could die and then she
prays that um some Reckoning of death
and destruction would come to Jason and
to glow and Kanan and their house now
this is a dangerous thing to say she's
in somebody else's Kingdom somebody
else's political community and everyone
knows what's going on and she is not
happy with it she's not accepting it
lying
down now in her own view as well as in
the view of the chorus and its leaders
meda's right to be angry and even to
wish to seek revenge on Jason her
Unfaithful husband why is this the case
well she betrayed out of love for Jason
before he even was her husband she even
killed her own brother as they were
pursuing uh in order to facilitate Jason
and her Escape after they had stolen the
Golden Fleece from kulus uh she says
that not only did she make it possible
for Jason to attain the thing that he
needed the Golden Fleece she kept him
from dying in the process so he owes her
not just the success of his Venture not
just the restoration of his own kingdom
but his very own
life uh to the Greeks she's considered
to be a barbarian but she's actually
from a semi Divine lineage her family is
descended from Helios the sun god so
she's not somebody to be treated badly
and she talks about bearing him children
and then she says something very
interesting she says I've given you
children and bearing a child is three
times the feat of going into a battle so
she's saying that women in a certain
sense are more
courageous than men who
fight why because child birth is painful
and dangerous and could lead to your own
death so when we look at that it kind of
seems like if anybody has Good Grounds
to be angry it would be Meda wouldn't it
she is the one who has the greatest
reason the greatest charge for being an
angry person and taking Revenge now the
very fact that she is so power powerful
and is known to be a
sorceress makes her a threat not just to
Jason but to the king cron and this
brings him into full conflict with her
because he is afraid uh for his own
daughter and then he becomes angry at
her so we see once again anger tends to
beget anger in at least some of the
people towards whom the anger is
directed at and so we get this encounter
with cran so cran says you Meda scowling
with rage against your husband I order
you to leave this land and go into Exile
taking your two children with you and
instantly I am the executor of this
degree I will not return home again
until I expel you from this land and
then Meda says I'm Ill treated why are
you exiling me
Kon and he says I am afraid that you
will do deadly harm to my daughter many
indications of this combin you are a
clever woman and skilled in many evil
Arts you are smarting with the loss of
your husband's love and I hear that you
are threatening this is the report
people bring to harm the bride her
father and her husband so I shall take
precautions before the event it's better
for me to incur your hatred now woman
than to be soft and incur it later on
and she says um uh you know some things
to him and then he says your words are
not are soothing to listen to but I'm
afraid in your heart you're plotting
some harm and he calls her a
hot-tempered woman and he says is easier
to guard against a clever woman who
keeps her own counsel so she can't even
you know we often say I can't win for
losing right no matter what she does she
is being viewed as a threat if she's
angry and she's saying I'm going to take
revenge she's a threat if she says H I
won't take revenge I'll get over this
kanan's like you're planning something
so um then we get some interactions
between Meda and Jason himself both of
them make cases to each other it's kind
of a a Judicial sort of um discussion
except they're arguing with each other
as you know couples off and do and um
they wind up in a state of disagreement
Jason is trying to calm Meda and then
we're going to see a seeming
reconciliation but it's not a
Reconciliation so in the first encounter
Jason as we often say throws fuel on the
fire he gives her more to be angry over
he claims the entire situation could be
afforded her unreasonable and
unpredictable rage has angered Creon and
Jason is the good guy he's interceded
for her and the children and he tells
her the sacrifices she made were not his
doing so he's not responsible for them
it's hers or loves so he doesn't bear
responsibility for that and then he
argues that in his actions he's being
wise and self-controlled and a friend to
her and the children and then finally
caps it by saying I didn't wrong you by
remarrying I'm trying to secure a place
for your children in Corinth bringing
them into the family house now what
happens to you you know you're your
collateral damage so to speak so this
makes her even more angry right and she
says I will accept no help from your
friends nor will I take anything from
you don't offer it the gifts of a base
man a ignoble man bring no benefit so
what we've got here is not just a clash
of emotions not just a personal conflict
not just a matter of um domestic dispute
but a real discussion about what's
expedient or useful versus what is right
or just Meda has Justice on her side in
in so far as she hasn't done anything
yet she is in the right and Jason is in
the wrong even after he's given his
arguments but this leads to her becoming
even more
angry and in the second encounter
between the two of
them she is going to portray herself as
seeing the error of her anger which is a
bit of a a blind right she says that
it's befitting that he put up with her
anger considering all of the actions of
love in the past on her part and then
she says you're intentions and actions
were were reasonable I should have gone
along and welcomed them as
well-intentioned and beneficial and she
actually calls her own anger pointless
mtin Thum right I got angry over nothing
mate is is empty and she says that it's
finished but she is not finished with
her anger and the seeming
reconciliation is actually part of her
plan for taking revenge on those who
have wronged her so what is she going to
do what is the retaliation or
retribution so first she gives a bridal
gift to Glow a poison bit of clothing
glow puts it on immediately starts
burning and dies cron uh comes to his
daughter's Aid and is also poisoned and
dies in horrible pain himself s so now
we've got two main characters off the
scene Jason is now left with no Patron
no no daddy-in-law right no wife no
Alliance so she's taken all of that away
from him now if she'd stopped there
maybe that would have been
acceptable um but she infamously goes
much further at least in uid play so
here's what she actually says talking
with the chorus
leader now I shall tell you of all of my
designs hear then words that will give
you no pleasure I shall send one of my
servants and ask Jason to come to see me
when he arrives as shall speak soothing
words to him and he he goes on right and
talks about the gifts and all that and
then he
says Ah me I groan at what a deed I must
do next I shall kill kill my children
and notice she doesn't say our children
his children I shall kill my children
there is no one who can rescue them when
I have utterly confounded the whole
house of Jason I shall leave the land in
flight from the murder of my own dear
sons having committed a most Unholy deed
the laughter of one's enemies is
unendurable my friends let that be as it
will what do I gain from living I have
no father no house no means to turn
aside Misfortune my mistake was when I
left my father's house persuaded by the
words of a Greek this man a god being my
helper will pay the price of my deed his
deeds to me he shall never from this day
he his children by me alive nor will he
beget children by his new bride since
that wretch must die a wretched death by
my poisons now notice this line let no
one think me weak temptable untroubled
no quite the opposite hurtful to foes to
friends kindly such persons live a life
of greatest
glory and the chorus leader
says since you've shared this plan with
me and since I wish to help you and
uphold the laws of society I urge you
not to do this
deed and then Meda says it cannot be
otherwise I excuse you for speaking thus
since you have not suffered as I have
and then the chorus leader says will you
bring yourself to kill your own
offspring and she says it is the way to
hurt my husband most so she's resolved
on it and she does kill the son she's
born to Jason now Jason arrives hoping
to save the children and in his own
anger he would avenge them but she is
already taking flight she's a Sorceress
in a chariot drawn by dragon
and the play concludes with a lengthy
bitter and inconclusive argument between
Jason and Meda he calls on the gods
because he can't do it to punish her and
she retorts that they will not listen to
the prayers of an oath breaker and this
is where it ends so you know again we we
see that anger leads to other
expressions of anger we see that anger
can go too far now in m
case there isn't any God who's stealing
her reason away so that her revenge
doesn't land on the people that she
intends it to hit instead what we see is
it is her own family that is destroyed
in the process Jason is Left Alive but
everything has been taken from him his
wife his children his new wife his
father-in-law
all of these sorts of
matters so uh we have here two different
Greek tragedies in which we see similar
depictions of anger using the same
language you know
hos
or this doesn't you know coincide of
course with what Plato and arist we've
discussed previously have made of anger
discussing these things but there is a
kind of continuity between what's
happened in the earlier writers uh
particularly Homer and hessed right and
what is going to be happening with anger
with these more theoretical treatments
so um that's all that I have for you now
as a a great opportunity for any sort of
uh discussion that you want to have I
haven't seen any question questions or
comments yet other than mark saying
hello but if anybody would like to join
in and ask something or say something
I'm perfectly happy to to entertain any
questions or comments insights
clarifications discussions um what do
you what do you have about these
otherwise we'll we'll finish up with the
session and we'll take this up again
next month but this time around
looking at some philosophical treatments
of anger rather than uh literary as
we've done the last few
times I'm not seeing any questions or
comments uh but then you know the
interface is is acting wonky so if
they're there and I'm not seeing them I
certainly uh apologize about that um
let's see if doing a pop out helps no
that's that's the same so I think a lot
of people just came along uh for the
ride perhaps and uh maybe in this first
one uh sh Shera says when will the next
session be conducted uh you can always
find that by going to the reason iio
events calendar or looking at YouTube
where uh these are already scheduled and
uh you can look at my Facebook page as
well where we have these as events um
any any questions comments about Meda or
Ajax or Greek tragedy more generally the
views on anger the vocabulary VOC
vocabulary being used and
invoked I'm not seeing any so I think
we'll draw this one to a successful
close and uh as I mentioned you can find
you know when the next ones will be
offered they're right there in the
channel uh on the main page you just
scroll down and you see upcoming live
streams for this and for other events uh
on my Facebook page the events as well
and um the reason I owe events calendar
I always put these things on there in
advance as well so I will see you next
time and hopefully uh we'll uh have a
bit more intense discussion of what is
going on in these texts so I'll see you
and uh thanks for
attending